what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I want to
talk about what I believe Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen will name their child
as of right now we still don't know how
many children they will have some people
say she could be pregnant with twins
while other people say she could be
pregnant with triplets which would play
into the dragon has three heads prophecy
I really don't know how many babies she
will have but I think it's safe to say
that she will at least have one the
evidence that foreshadowed this during
season seven was absolutely overwhelming
I made a video just last week and in
that video I compiled multiple scenes of
foreshadowing along with a clip from the
writers of the show who basically
confirmed she will be pregnant just in
case some of you didn't see that video I
will play it after I tell you what I
think their baby's name could be if Jon
and Daenerys do have a son together I
believe I found the answer for what the
name is I have seen some people try and
guess what they could name their baby
but I haven't seen too many people use
any of the evidence from the books I
know the show has moved past the books
now but they still use a ton of
references from them and this name was
said during one of John's chapters and a
Storm of Swords which is a book they
adapted very well but they couldn't use
this yet until the right time and next
season would be the perfect time because
Jon Snow will finally have a child of
his own to name I have heard some people
say that if they have a boy they could
name him Eddard after Jon Snow's father
Ned Stark was not Jon Snow's biological
father but you know what I mean he
raised Jon Snow as his son and Jon very
well may want to honor him by giving his
own son the name Eddard even if the baby
takes the Targaryen last name this was
actually going to be the name of Robb
Stark's son during the red wedding this
is what Talisa said she wanted to name
their baby and it was a very touching
scene boy or girl
[Music]
I don't know but if it's a boy I know
what we should name him oh do you it
seems to me the father should have some
say in his sons naming hey Dad
unfortunately we all know how that event
ended since little Eddard was never born
the showrunners might decide to use that
name again for John and Danny's baby
that's if they do in fact have a son and
personally I wouldn't mind one bit if
that's what they named their baby Eddard
is a fine name for a boy but it wouldn't
be my first option for a prediction if
John and Daenerys happen to have a girl
I have heard people say that they might
name her Liana
after Jon Snow's mother I wouldn't mind
that either Liana is a beautiful name
and I don't think Daenerys would mind
that either she knows that's the woman
her brother Rhaegar basically died for
they could give the child on northern
name for its first name then make its
last name Targaryen but Liana would not
be my first option for a prediction
either in the books Jon Snow briefly
considers having a son of his own and
when he thinks about this there is only
one name that comes to mind when he
considers what he would name him at the
end of the third book of Storm of Swords
Jon Snow is at the wall and this is when
Stannis Baratheon is at the wall - some
of you should remember this from the
show in season five Stannis one at Jon's
helped to win over the north
Stannis wanted to legitimize Jon by
giving him the last name stark and he
was also going to give him wonderful
don't know what I have left to give you
you can give me the north I can't
even if I wanted to on the busted snow
kneel before me lay your sword at my
feet
pledge me your service in your eyes
again as John Stark Lord of Winterfell
[Music]
Stannis offers this same thing to John
in the books but he will only offer it
under a few conditions
Stannis wanted John to marry one of the
wildlings in order to make the northern
and wildling alliance even stronger in
the books this woman's name is Val and
she is the sister to man's his wife she
is said to be very beautiful in John
Snow even thinks about how attractive
she is on more than one occasion but vow
is a stranger to him John does not know
her at all
and vows not to tape a woman to be
forced into a marriage John wanted to be
legitimized as a stark and he did one
Winterfell but he couldn't do it under
these conditions but he did consider it
and this is what he thought it seemed an
easy choice when he thought of it in
those terms though if he Girt had still
been alive it might have been even
easier Val was a stranger to him she was
not hard on the eyes certainly and she
had been sister to mance rayder's Queen
but still I would need to steal her if I
wanted her love but she might give me
children I might someday hold a son of
my own blood in my arms a son was
something Jon Snow had never dared dream
of since he decided to live his life on
the wall I could name him robb Val would
want to keep her sister's son but we
could foster him at Winterfell in
Gilley's boy as well so as you can see
the only time Jon ever considered having
a son there was only one name he could
imagine naming him and that was Rob
after his half-brother Robb Stark I
think since then and Dave have adapted
so much of a Storm of Swords to the
television show they may have had plans
to adapt this piece of information when
the time came for Jon to have a son they
could name him Rob Targaryen giving it a
nice and fire name like I said at the
beginning of the video we still don't
know what their child will be it could
be a boy or it could be a girl or maybe
even both since she could have twins
triplets or so on and so forth but I
think if they do have a son together Jon
will want to name him Rob since this is
the one name he considered naming his
son in the books let me know what you
think about this idea though do you
believe they will use this name or do
you think they will use another one for
those of you who are still one
adding a child together I will recommend
that you keep watching the video to see
all the evidence that was foreshadowed
in season 7 but if you already watched
that video last week then I just want to
thank you for stopping by and watching
today's video I really appreciate that
along with everyone who supports to the
channel on patreon do it
- there is a price of gold whatever you
want it's not a matter of gold this is
blood-magic only death pays for life
Daenerys Targaryen is 100% without a
doubt pregnant by John Snow
there was so much heavy foreshadowing at
the end of season seven I think almost
everyone feels the same way but until
Season eight errors we still don't know
if this will become a fact or not but I
may have found some new evidence that
proves she is and will be pregnant next
season don't ask me why but last night I
was up until about 5:00 a.m. listening
to the damn commentary tracks on this
season 7 blu-ray for those of you that
don't know the season 7 blu-ray has some
bonus features and one of those features
has commentary by some of the actors and
writers on a few episodes but the one I
am referring to is the season 7 finale
the very last episode of the season
during this episode there is commentary
by Kit Harington Lena Headey and Dan and
Dave which are the writers and producers
of this show they basically just talk
about the episode and how some of the
scenes were filmed and things like that
but the writers of this show said
something very interesting that may
reveal a huge plot point next season
before I play the clips I just want to
preface this by pointing something out
that may explain why they were so
comfortable with saying this in the
first place
the one guy left listening to this DVD -
commentary is a is depraved no offense
to you surf but I'm just saying no
offense mom as they were talking about
the episode the writer started to joke
about how ridiculous it was to record
commentary for the DVDs in the first
place they know that no one ever really
listens to these bonus features so they
started to joke about how only one
person is probably even listening to
what they were saying about the episode
and I think that I'm joking around about
that may have caused them to put their
guard down momentarily they didn't
expect too many people to listen to them
talk about things that typically aren't
very important but thankfully I actually
sit there and listen to all of it
because what they said later on may have
been a massive spoiler as they were
talking about the episode we get to the
scene
the dragon pit with Jon Snow and
Daenerys Targaryen and this is when
Daenerys says she can no longer have
children because marry master said she
couldn't and that's when John says maybe
she wasn't a reliable source of
information meaning maybe Daenerys can't
get pregnant after all but the most
important thing about this scene is what
the writer said as they were watching it
just take a listen for yourself yes she
says the unknown she can't have children
we'll see about that you haven't met me
little Johnson you have another little
job that was kid Harrington who plays
John Snow and that was also Dane and
Dave who are the writers of this show
when kid Harrington says Daenerys can't
get pregnant the writer said we will see
about that
then they started laughing about
Daenerys meeting the Little John Snow
let's listen to that one more time just
in case you were reading the chat or
something like that pay very close
attention yes she says the unknown she
can't have children
we'll see about that you ever met me
Little John see and I'm at the middle
job no I don't know about you but that
sounded like a confirmation to me dan
and Dave are cocky just enough to say
something like that during a DVD
commentary that they think no one is
listening to in the first place I'm sure
some of you will think they were just
joking the whole time and it doesn't
actually mean anything but I would have
to disagree
I think they let their guard down long
enough to let something slip when you
combine this with all the heavy
foreshadowing at the end of season 7 I
would bet money on Daenerys being
pregnant next season in the last two
episodes of the season there were over a
half a dozen hints at Daenerys being
able to have children again in the
future
the first subtle hint was during
Daenerys antarians conversation about
succession and who will role after the
Narus has gone how do we ensure your
vision indoors after you break the wheel
how do we make sure it stays broken
you want to know who sits on the Iron
Throne after I'm dead is that it
you say you can't have children but
there are other ways of choosing a
successor Tyrion wanted to know how
Daenerys intended on keeping the wheel
broken once she dies but she didn't want
to think about this before she even said
upon the Iron Throne but this was a big
concern for Tyrion because he assumed
the nares can't have any children
because she said so herself that may not
seem like foreshadowing when you just
watch that scene by itself but in the
same episode there was another hint with
Jon Snow when he went beyond the wall
Jon tried to give Longclaw back to the
Mormont's because he didn't feel like it
was right to keep something that had
been in their family for centuries but
Jorah Mormont knew his father wanted
John to have the sword and he knows the
sword will serve Jon well and his
children after him a full fitted the
right to claim the soul
it's yours it serve you well and your
children after you
even though John and Daenerys just met
you could see they were starting to like
each other in the longing looks they
gave each other hinted at something more
than just a military alliance it was
only a matter of time before they began
a romantic relationship and it will be
John seed that finally allows Daenerys
to have a healthy baby at the end of the
same episode is when Viserion is killed
by the night king after John makes it
back to the wall he has a touching scene
with Daenerys where she says the dragons
were her children and they would be the
only children she would ever have the
dragons are my children they're the only
children Oliver
do you understand the dragons would have
been the only children she would have if
they had all lived until Danny died but
vissarion's death was a payment for life
only death can pay for life and her
losing that child will grant her the
opportunity to have an actual child of
her own with John Snow in the very next
episode there are several more instances
of foreshadowing in the dragon pit John
hands Daenerys a piece of skull from a
dragon and I believe this was symbolic
for John giving Daenerys an actual baby
dragon meaning a child then they focus
the camera on them handing this dragon
skull back and forth to each other and
it was just another subtle hand at them
having their own baby dragon together
then of course this is immediately
followed with their conversation about
Daenerys being the only Targaryen left
which we know isn't true because John is
a Targaryen but not only that they will
produce an heir together when your
family hasn't seen its end you're still
here I can't have children who told you
that there weren't you murdered my
husband has it occurred to you she might
not have been a reliable source of
information Danny says she can't have
kids and John says marry master was full
of [ __ ] yes you can't have kids and he
intends on perving this later in the
episode when they have epic boat sex
together when you combine all of this
with what the writers of the show said
during the DVD commentary I think it's
blatantly obvious what will happen next
but let me know what you think do you
think the writers confirm Daenerys is
pregnancy when they said we will see
about her not being able to have
children or do you think they were only
joking and all of this foreshadowing
means nothing I am curious to know if
there was anyone out there who believes
John and Daenerys will not have a kid
together
so put all your thoughts and questions
down below in the comment section I want
to thank everyone for stopping by to
check out the video I really do
appreciate that and I also want to thank
all of my patreon supporters have a
great day everyone I'll see you tomorrow
when I upload the next video bye
[Music]